und wir erinnern uns an ein
exklusivinterview der bundes
außenministerin hierbei bild live das
rund 24 stunden zuvor gewesen die grüne
außenministerin annalena baerbock sie
kam mit kanadas aussenministerin mélanie
julie hier jetzt axel-springer-haus
hierzu bild live und natürlich war das
eine abrechnung mit vladimir putin hier
und sie sagte in diesem interview mit
bild chef johannes bühl diesen satz
wir versuchen alles zu tun um diesen
krieg zu stoppen wir müssen aber auch
sehr deutlich sagen dass dieser
präsident derzeit offenbar nicht zu
stoppen ist weil er jegliche menschliche
grenzen überschreite wir müssen sehen
dass dieser präsident dieser krieg sehr
offenbar derzeit nicht zu stoppen ist
darüber sprechen wir hier im studio mit
bildpolitik stefan schäfer ist er nicht
zu stoppen was sagen euch im
politikressort die experten oder wenn er
doch zu stoppen ist wie ja wir haben
heute in der tat viel herumtelefoniert
um von ehemaligen politikern von aktiven
politikern aber auch beispielsweise von
militärhistoriker oder auch von
bischöfen zu erfahren was könnte man
eigentlich tun um wladimir putin zu
stoppen was sind eigentlich die
möglichkeit und ganz interessantes
beispielsweise was der ehemalige
bundesverteidigungsminister franz josef
jung erklärt hat er hat gesagt ganz klar
wir müssen sofort aufhören öl und gas
aus russland zu importieren also ein
importstopp um putin auch die
finanzielle basis für die finanzierung
des krieges zu nehmen genauso hat sich
geäußert marie-agnes strack-zimmermann
die fdp-politikerin die chefin des
verteidigungsausschusses die sagt auch
stoppt sofort die öl- und gaslieferungen
aus russland dann and civil putin das
nötige geld für den krieg aber wir haben
auch gesprochen oder die kollegen mit
dem minister militär historiker sönke
neitzel beispielsweise und der sagte
ganz interessanter weise er glaubt dass
dieser konflikt nur noch auf dem
schlachtfeld gelöst werden kann also er
sagt das ist jetzt ein konflikt der ist
nur militärisch zu lösen entweder
gewinnt die ukraine oder die russin
gewinnen
chinas präsident gesagt er hatte eine
entscheidende rolle möglicherweise auch
in der vermittlung aber erst danach sagt
neitzel werden eigentlich diplomatische
beziehungen wieder möglich sein auch
gespräche wie dann der frieden genau
ausgestaltet werden kann was sagen die
experten was sagt ihr dazu dass man
ausgerechnet mit anderen diktatoren
jetzt versucht putin zu stoppen mit
hilfe von erdogan mit hilfe von she das
ist schon sehr sehr bizarr am ende geht
es aber das muss man dann auch in so
einer situation immer wieder sagen
natürlich darum dieses blutvergießen so
schnell wie möglich zu stoppen vor allem
putin zu stoppen und wenn die türkei die
am morgen ausrichter dieser
friedensverhandlungen ist dafür die
geeignete bühne da ist das sicherlich in
ordnung hauptsache putin wird in die
schranken verwiesen interessant
vielleicht noch der hinweis auf die
ehemalige grünen politikerin marieluise
beck mit der haben die kollegen heute
auch gesprochen und die sagt
beispielsweise auch ganz klar die russen
die in die ukraine entschuldigung um die
russen in die knie zu zwingen braucht
die ukraine auch bessere und modernere
waffen auch aus dem westen also die
spricht sich für waffenlieferungen aus
und auch für einen sofortigen öl und gas
boykott aus russland aber interessant
auch die grünen sind da mittlerweile
deutlich deutlich stärker auf der seite
der ukraine was waffenlieferungen angeht
als noch vor einigen wochen der fall war
so also könnte putin doch noch zu
stoppen sein nachdem die außenministerin
annalena baerbock vor 24 stunden hier im
studio eben diesen satz sagte der zeit
scheint er nicht zu stoppen der wladimir
putin jetzt hast du die gaslieferung und
öllieferungen aus russland schon
angesprochen auch da formiert sich der
widerstand gegen die bundesregierung
international sowieso aber jetzt auch
national es gibt fast kaum jemand mehr
der nicht regiert der nicht will dass
die gas und öl lieferungen eingestellt
werden friedrich merz hat sich vor
wenigen minuten nämlich im bundestag so
geäußert
wir wollen nicht warten bis andere den
vorschlag machen und deutschland dann
wieder hinterher kommt oder warten bis
vielleicht putin selbst den gashahn dort
an dieser stelle abdreht deswegen ist
unser vorschlag ist unsere bitte unsere
forderung auch an die bundesregierung
keinen weiteren bezug von gas aus der
pipeline nord stream 1 wir wollen nicht
warten sagt friedrich merz also die
wirtschaftspartei der wirtschaftsmann
friedrich merz der ist jetzt treibende
kraft dort aus der oppositionsrolle
heraus und ja treibt die bundesregierung
dorthin nazi um eins dicht zu machen ja
wenn man das thema wirtschaft schon
nennt und du hast es gerade auch erwähnt
und der wirtschaftsmann friedrich merz
argumentiert zu dann ist das glaube ich
am ende immer eine frage was ist
eigentlich die noch schlechtere variante
unter allen schlechten varianten und die
frage ist ja wenn wir putin weiter
finanzieren täglich mit je nachdem
zwischen 200 millionen und einer
milliarde euro die wir ihm bezahlen für
sein gassen sein öl dann verlängert das
den krieg die folgewirkung für die
wirtschaft könnten dramatisch sein jetzt
kann man sagen im gegenteil dazu können
wir die gas und öl jetzt sofort stoppen
dann hat die wirtschaft auch dramatische
folgen die mögen aber vielleicht kürzer
sein und nicht ganz so schlimm wie das
was wir erleben wenn der krieg noch
länger anhält und das seiner abwägung
und ich glaube in der abwägung hat
friedrich merz er vollkommen recht
gesagt lasst es uns jetzt stoppen dann
gibt es einen hoffentlich jetzt ein
schnelles ende und dann sind die
folgewirkungen für alle die dranhängen
für die ukraine für die leben der
menschen aber auch dann für die
wirtschaft und für uns hier in
deutschland nicht so drastisch als wenn
putin noch länger morgen kein leben wir
hier gerade die nächste wende der
bundesregierung also das ist ja nicht
irgendwas wenn der oppositionsführer
sich da jetzt fest legt das ist neu
wenige stunden alt die opposition sagt
gashahn aus russland die pipeline nord
stream 1 zu sperren ist das die wende
wird scholz in kürze folgen also es ist
die wände zumindest in der opposition
denn bis vor kurzem klang auch friedrich
merz noch ein bisschen anders taktgeber
war dort
also norbert röttgen sein widersacher um
den parteivorsitz der hat ganz klar die
marschroute vorgegeben auf dieses
friedrich merz jetzt eingeschränkt ob
die regierung umfeld wie schnell das
kann man jetzt noch nicht sagen ich
glaube dass die regierung gar nicht
anders kann als innerhalb der nächsten
tage auch zu sagen wir müssen die öl-
und gasimporte stoppen die amerikaner
haben vorgelegt die briten sind auf
einem ähnlichen weg von daher wird es
wieder dann deutschland sein das als
allerletztes reagiert das kann sich
diese bundesregierung eigentlich gar
nicht leisten bei 1 problemen die für
das land dann durch so einen öl- und
gasimporte entstehen würden danke an
bildpolitik chef jan schäfer antwort auf
die frage wie kann man putin noch
stoppen danke dir